when Dorothy was a little girl she was
fascinated by her goldfish her father
explained to her that fish swim by
quickly wagging their tails to propel
themselves through the water without
hesitation little Dorothy responded yes
daddy and fish swim backwards by wagging
their heads in her mind it was a fact as
true as any other fish swim backwards by
wagging their heads she believed it our
lives are full of fish swimming
backwards we make assumptions and faulty
leaps of logic we harbor bias we know
that we are right and they are wrong we
fear the worst
we strive for unattainable perfection we
tell ourselves what we can and cannot do
in our minds fish swim by and reverse
frantically wagging their heads and we
don't even notice them I'm going to tell
you five facts about myself one fact is
not true one I graduated from Harvard at
19 with an honours degree in mathematics
two I currently run a construction
company in Orlando 3 I starred on a
television sitcom 4 I lost my sight to a
rare genetic eye disease 5 I served as a
law clerk to two US Supreme Court
justices which facts not true actually
they're all true yeah they're all true
at this point most people really only
care about the television show
I know this from experience okay so the
show was NBC's Saved by the Bell the new
class and I played weasel was L who was
the sort of dorky nerdy character on the
show which made it a very major acting
challenge for me as a thirteen-year-old
boy now did you struggle with number
four my blindness why is that we make
assumptions about so-called disabilities
as a blind man I confront others
incorrect assumptions about my abilities
every day my point today is not about my
blindness however it's about my vision
going blind taught me to live my life
eyes wide open it taught me to spot
those backwards swimming fish that our
minds create going blind cast them into
focus what does it feel like to see it's
immediate and passive you open your eyes
and there's the world seeing is
believing
sight is truth right well that's what I
thought then from age 12 to 25 my
retinas progressively deteriorated my
sight became an increasingly bizarre
carnival funhouse hall of mirrors and
illusions the salesperson I was relieved
to spot in a store was really a
mannequin reaching down to wash my hands
I suddenly saw it was a urinal I was
touching not a sink when my fingers felt
its true shape a friend described the
photograph in my hand and only then I
could see the image depicted objects
appeared morphed and disappeared in my
reality it was difficult and exhausting
to see I pieced together fragmented
transitory images consciously analyzed
the clues search for some logic in my
crumbling kaleidoscope until I saw
nothing at all I learned that what we
see is not Universal truth it is not
objective reality what we see is a
unique personal virtual reality that is
masterfully constructed by our brain let
me explain with a bit of amateur
neuroscience your visual cortex takes up
about 30% of your brain that's compared
to approximately 8% for touch and 2 to 3
percent for hearing every second your
eyes can send your visual cortex as many
as 2 billion pieces of information the
rest of your body can send your brain
only an additional billion so sight is
one third of your brain by volume and
can claim about two thirds of your
brains processing resources it's no
surprise then that the illusion of sight
is so compelling but make no mistake
about it sight is an illusion here's
where it gets interesting to create the
experience of sight your brain
references your conceptual understanding
of the world other knowledge your
memories opinions emotions mental
attention all of these things and far
more are linked in your brain to your
site these linkages work both ways and
usually occur subconsciously so for
example what you see impacts how you
feel and the way you feel can literally
change what you see numerous studies
demonstrate this if you are asked to
estimate the walking speed of a man in a
video for example your answer will be
different if you're told to think about
cheetahs or turtles a hill appears
steeper if you've just exercised and a
landmark
appears farther away if you're wearing a
heavy backpack we have arrived at a
fundamental contradiction what you see
is a complex mental construction of your
own making but you experience it
passively as a direct representation of
the world around you you create your own
reality and you believe it I believe
mine until it broke apart the
deterioration of my eyes shattered the
illusion you see sight is just one way
we shape our reality we create our own
realities in many other ways
take fear as just one example your fears
distort your reality under the warped
logic of fear anything is better than
the uncertain fear fills the void at all
costs passing off what you dread for
what you know offering up the worst in
place of the ambiguous substituting
assumption for reason psychologists have
a great term for it awful Isaac right
fear replaces the unknown with the awful
now fear is self realizing when you face
the greatest need to look outside
yourself and think critically fear beats
a retreat deep inside your mind
shrinking and distorting your view
drowning your capacity for critical
thought with a flood of disruptive
emotions when you face a compelling
opportunity to take action
fear lulls you into inaction enticing
you to passively watch its prophesies
fulfill themselves when I was diagnosed
with my blinding disease
I knew blindness would ruin my life
blindness was a death sentence for my
independence it was the end of
achievement for me blindness meant I
would live an unremarkable life small
and sad and likely alone I knew it this
was a fiction born of my fears but I
believed it it was a lie but it was my
reality
just like those backwards swimming fish
in little Dorothy's mind if I had not
confronted the reality of my fear I
would have lived it I am certain of that
so how do you live your life eyes wide
open it is a learned discipline it can
be taught it can be practiced I'll
summarize very briefly hold yourself
accountable for every moment every
thought every detail see beyond your
fears recognize your assumptions harness
your internal strength silence or
internal critic correct your
misconceptions about luck and about
success accept your strengths and your
this is and understand the difference
open your hearts to your bountiful
blessings your fears your critics your
heroes your villains they are your
excuses rationalizations shortcuts
justifications your surrender
they are fictions you perceive as
reality choose to see through them
choose to let them go you are the
creator of your reality with that
empowerment comes complete
responsibility I chose to step out of
fears tunnel into terrain uncharted and
undefined I chose to build there a
blessed life far from alone I share my
beautiful life with Dorothy my beautiful
wife with our triplets whom we call the
trip skis and with the latest addition
to the family
sweet baby Clementine what do you fear
what lies do you tell yourself how do
you embellish your truth and write your
own fictions what reality are you
creating for yourself in your career and
personal life in your relationships and
in your heart and soul your backward
swimming fish do you great harm they
exact a toll in missed opportunities and
unrealized potential and they engender
insecurity and distrust where you seek
fulfillment and connection I urge you to
search them out Helen Keller said that
the only thing worse than being blind is
having sight but no vision for me going
blind was a profound blessing because
blindness gave me vision I hope you can
see what I see thank you
either before you leave the stage just
that question this is an audience of
entrepreneurs of doers of innovators you
are a CEO of a company down in Florida
and many are probably wondering how is
it to be blind CEO what kind of specific
challenges do you have and how do you
overcome them well the biggest challenge
became a blessing I don't get visual
feedback from people what I know is
there yeah so for example in my
leadership team meetings I don't see
facial expressions or gestures I've
learned to solicit a lot more verbal
feedback I basically you don't force
people to tell me what they think and in
this respect it's it's become like I
said a real blessing for me personally
and for my company because we
communicate at a far deeper level we
avoid ambiguities and most important my
team knows that what they think truly
matters Isak thank you for coming with
that thank you
you